and basically you know what ellipse is
an oval okay and the distance from the
center to the vertices we call that
distance a okay the distance from the
center to the co vertices this narrower
direction we call that distance B and
then the distance from the center to the
full side we call that distance C now if
any of this sounds confusing to you I'll
have links to other videos that I did
talking about graphing ellipses and a
little bit more a basic and introductory
so you can check that out if you aren't
familiar with ellipses a little bit
already but the general equation you can
see is X minus H squared plus y minus K
squared is equal to one and we've got
these denominators a squared + B squared
but remember you know the a squared + B
squared can actually switch the a is the
larger one and that's going to give you
the distance from the center to the
vertices and the vertices are gonna be
on that longer axis okay that major axis
so when this ellipse here a is actually
horizontal it's from the center left and
right okay in this case the a would be
underneath the x squared term and this
problem here or in this graph here I
should say the a is going to be
underneath the Y squared term okay and
then the h and the K pick up the graph
and shift it left and right up and down
and then we have an equation that
relates a B and C that C squared is
equal to a squared minus B squared okay
kind of like Pythagorean theorem but
you're subtracting and then eccentricity
is defined as C divided by a okay so
sometimes you have problems that talk
about eccentricities and this problem
we're not really going to work with work
with that so I'll just kind of skip over
that for right now but let's see what
they give us here they give us the
vertices are negative 1 negative 3
negative 7 negative 3 and the full set
negative 2 negative 3 negative 6
negative 3 so I'm going to sketch a
graph of that but I wanted to mention
before I get into this problem further
if you're preparing for the AC T or the
SAT and you want additional help
check out my two video courses that I
put together for you to help you boost
your score you know improve your
understanding you know and do better on
those tests overall I go through a
teaching section we have example
problems there's opportunities for you
to practice and it goes over some
concepts and expected problems that you
would likely see on those tests so if
you're preparing for those definitely
check out those video courses but let's
continue with this problem what we want
to do is we want to sketch these points
here to get an eye
while this graph looks like so we've got
negative 1 negative 3 right there that's
the vertex and we also have a negative 7
negative 3 that's our other vertex right
there and then halfway in between those
vertices is the center point so one way
to do that is to add the XS together and
divide by 2 so that's negative 8 divided
by 2 being negative 4 so you can see 1 2
3 negative 4 negative 3 that's our
Center so I'll just write that down so
we have that ok now
the full-size are at negative 2 negative
3 and negative 6 negative 3 okay so
there's our full side right there so you
can see our ellipse is going to be
longer in the horizontal direction okay
because the vertices in the full set on
that major axis that longer axis so so
far what we have let's see we can write
down what we have we've got X minus
negative 4 which is X plus 4 squared
plus y minus negative 3 which is y plus
3 squared is equal to 1 the distance
from the center to the vertex we call
that distance a ok and so what is that
distance well you can see it's 1 2 3
okay so that's going to be 3 squared
which is 9 now notice I'm putting that
underneath the X because that's going in
the X or horizontal direction okay if it
was going like this direction is longer
in the vertical direction it would go
underneath the Y okay so we've got our a
squared now we're looking for is our B
squared right there so remember there's
an equation that relates all those
together it's C squared equals a squared
minus B squared so let's go ahead and do
that so C squared is equal to a squared
minus B squared C remembers the distance
from the center to the focus in that
case you can see it's 2 so 2 squared is
4a squared we figured out was 9 right
because that's the distance from the
center to the vertex
squared minus B squared so you can see
that B squared is equal to 5 if you
solve this equation so this is going to
be 5 right there now if you want to take
the graph a little bit further take a
square root of 5 which is about what is
that a little bit over 2 right so if I
go up let's say a little bit over 2
right about there down a little bit over
2 that's gonna be our graph right there
a pretty good sketch ok but what we were
after in this problem was the equation
of the ellipse and that's what we have
right here so I hope this helps you
understand how to find the equation of
an ellipse when you're given the
vertices in the foci subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring I have over 400 some
videos on there right now as of this
video and there's a lot of helpful
information there and I look forward to
seeing the future videos so I'll talk to
you soon